all right you're done let's start by
uncommenting out that text as you can
see you need that forecast ring to pass
on to our detail activity so what do we
use to get that forecast ring well we're
lucky here because we actually get the
adapter view passed in all we have to do
is cast it to simple cursor adapter and
then we can get the cursor we can move
it to our position then we can use
string dot format to get a formatted
string based upon the values of our
columns note once again the nice use of
our column indices one ending curly
brace and let's move that intent stuff
inside of there and that's it now we'll
be able to click on it again and it'll
actually go to our normal detail view
let's try it out so here we are there's
our list view we can go right into
details pretty cool however we change
our temperature units to imperial here
doesn't actually update it would be nice
of that he was based on the same kind of
cursor model we have here something that
was observing with a Content observer
and would actually update when we
changed our setting